[Music]
Selena Gomez's
fans prove they've got her back those
can be a nasty place designer Stephano
cabana is in hot water once again after
making a negative comments about
Selena's appearance on Instagram I
always hope that the people I'm involved
with or support me can just kind of
spread love with a map earlier this week
the catwalk italia posted a 5 photo
split of the 25 year old singer rocking
different red outfits along with the
caption selena gomez rocks red dresses
choose your fav one two three four or
five Gabbana who is one-half the
legendary Italian fashion brand Dolce &
Gabbana commented on the photo writing
this italian phrase which roughly
translates to she's so ugly or the
slightly softer google translation it is
bad funny enough gomez is actually
wearing Dolce & Gabbana in the far-right
pic de Bono's comments ignited a social
media firestorm with fans immediately
jumping to Selena's defense 13 reasons
why star Tommy Dorfman responded quote
you are tired and over your homophobic
misogynistic body shaming existence will
not thrive in 2018 it is no longer
tolerable or chic please take many seats
another user commented quote how dare
you you a fashion designer whose job has
been to empower women around the world
to be strong brave and to love the body
they are in was it all hypocrisy the 55
year old designer has yet to respond but
it appears he did turn off the comment
feature on his own Instagram account
[Music]
of course this isn't the first time he's
landed himself in the middle of
controversy in 2015 he and Dominique o
Dulci famously ruffled feathers with
their candid views on gay parenting and
children born through IVF
[Music]